so the question is solved right it's
find what X is such that five the banner
x will be 17 okay now you have a look at
this question tell me just stop the face
of it there's not much written there
what makes this question different from
the others that we've been dealing with
so far yeah oh this thing that this one
right yeah the numbers is like I could
try numbers in X right I could try
numbers in it
I could try zebra find a pair 0 b1 I
could try 1 5 ^ 1 is 5
I could try to 5 squared is 25
hold on I went from 5 to 25 I've already
blown past the answer I wanted 17 so my
number is some way between 1 & 2 and
it's gonna be like who knows exactly
like you could sit on your calculator
for a long time actually
you'll probably sit there for an
indifferent amount of time trying to
guess right what X is going to be okay
in fact X is irrational so you will
never be able to put all the numbers in
because it goes on forever so how can I
solve this thing if not it doesn't
magically come out to a nice neat number
I'm gonna show you okay first thing I
want to suggest is excuse me I would
usually rewrite this in Log form right
now don't write this down how do i
rewrite this in Log form this is a new
next log base yep log base 5 yes equals
x okay now that's what I want okay
but that's a dead end like you've got a
calculator it can do two kinds of logs
with different bases one of them is 10
because that's scientific notation like
I was mentioning and you have scientific
calculators the other one is a different
weird number about 2.7 which you'll make
next year and I can explain that for you
if you like after this but neither of
them is 5 right you can't do on your
calculator straight away I'm gonna place
5 of anything okay so at the moment this
looks like a dead end looks like a dead
end
right so therefore I come back to here
now I want you to remember we've been
saying logs expansions they're just
functions right or any best functions
okay so for example if I have a number
like say okay - do you agree is 8
divided by 4
okay with that so therefore I could do a
function to both sides yeah right for
example I could say you guys in the trig
functions I can go sign two equals sign
804 they'll be fine
I can do a function of both sides I
could do I could square both sides two
squared then we ate over four square
these two things are the same sorry
these two things are the same I can do
any function I like to both sides and
it's all good okay so here's the
function I'm going to do I'm going to do
log base 10 I'm choosing base 10 just
because your calculator has bass tenor
you can actually choose anymore
any molecule like but if you have you
kept me there hopefully not because
we're gonna need it a second want base
10 of both sides alright so I have this
on the left hand side and I have log
base 10 of that on the right hand side
so I refer to this line as taking logs
of both sides okay these two things are
equal so log of this and load of that
should also be equal are you okay with
that
you happy okay now look at what we've
got think again of your sort of tool
belts of different things you can do
what do you see on the left hand side
yeah fantastic
I'll go pal what happening here right so
that X you can cut out with the power
and got the front like so and
remembering that what I want to solve is
X I want to make X the subject of the
equation what do I do to both sides I
divide by this guy right you see that
that gets rid of him from the left-hand
side and you just have this now this you
can put in your calculator and actually
would like you to do it just input for
me
Blagh you'll see excuse me the log
button is at the top right of your or
pretty close to the top right have your
calculator and you should get a number
with a whole bunch of decimal places
after it
he's got them 1.76 okay now does this
match what we're expecting remember when
we tried our numbers from the game we
said dummy we said 1 it's too small too
it's too big right
so therefore here's that number it's
right in between okay and in fact we
don't calculate it's still there you can
insert 5 press your power button and it
stick the answer in right and then keen
equals and sure enough you should get
exactly 17 now just as a tease for
Thursday let's see sometimes they go do
you see just we pack up remember we've
got here it was a dead end
do you remember that I was like am I
supposed to do PR but then when i
simplified it
I found it looked like that does that
not look very very similar okay now
these are connected I'm going to show
you exactly how on Thursday all right
off you go